[Music]
I'm James Allen I'm a data scientist at
a consultancy called sand table we work
with agent based models I'll explain
that in a bit more detail in a moment
but essentially it's just computer
simulations and yeah I'll just describe
a few a particular straw project that I
worked on on looking at social quality
and particularly around the issue of
inheriting wealth so the question that
we need to think about here is what
happens when you die now I'm not talking
for softkey or anything like that of
course just being in a very practical
materialistic sense what happens to the
wealth that you have accrued over your
lifetime obviously you choose what where
this goes you choose who inherits from
you if you write a will most people if
they have a surviving partner will give
their wealth or most of it to them or
maybe to their children if they have
children some people might choose though
to pass it down further along to lower
generations to their grandchildren or
their great-grandchildren or potentially
even further down the line obviously
when you're making this decision the
things probably make foremost in your
mind is how will it affect their lives
how that affect my children's life if
they get an inheritance from me the
question that is understandably not
asked as often but is arguably equally
important is one of the long-term
effects on society
now this perhaps isn't going to play in
so much when you're making your own
individual decision but there are other
decisions that need to be taken such as
house pre-setup inheritance tax
structures and how can we sort of make
things easier for people to make the
choice that will produce the sort of
more equal or better Society depending
on how you want to find better in the
future and this is the sort of work that
was done a lot and you may have heard of
the the nudge unit which was
a sort of policy unit that was set up
under the Blair government headed by the
sky David Halpern and he talks about
this particular issue of inheritance
rules in this book little and wealth of
nations and he made the argument that we
should create simple descendants trusts
to encourage people to bequeath their
assets to their grandchildren and
great-grandchildren rather than leading
them to their children
so essentially you skip out the
generation immediately below you in your
inheritance and pass it straight down
whatever wealth you have to the
generations underneath them he made the
argument for this former social equality
point of view you're saying even if you
are quite wealthy is very likely that at
least some of your grandchildren and
great-grandchildren we've dropped out of
your social class so the idea is that if
you encourage people to set up these
sorts of trusts then at least some of
the time it's going to benefit people
who would otherwise have been quite poor
relatively who will by virtue of having
a relatively wealthy great-grandparents
for example will then get a lump sum of
cash to help them out now you may have
seen a similar thing been used last year
as Gavin bar well who's the the housing
minister during the Conservative Party
conference he was talking event and
describes how his own mother had not
through a formal descendants trust but
had done exactly the same thing in that
when she died instead of leaving her
house to Gavin and his brother she
passed it straight down to their
children and Gavin Barwell despite being
the immediate loser in this situation
was talking about this as a positive
thing you know he was encouraging people
to do the same he was taking a slightly
different viewpoint from what
David Halpern had been suggesting in
that rather than focusing on on the
quality sort of across people of a given
generation he was pointing out that by
passing down to your grandchildren your
giving
then sort of an injection of wealth at
an earlier point in their lives where
arguably it's more useful to them and
politically this is often framed in
terms of housing and so it's talked
about it being a useful way to get your
grandchildren onto the housing ladder
now this is not a universally popular
idea
and there's the 9th of October on the
10th of October the prime minister
spokesman made it very clear that number
10 has no interest in this idea at all
and no it's not going to the government
policy is not something they're
interested in doing essentially it's
very difficult for politicians to get
involved inheritance tax because it does
kick up an awful lot of emotions it's
something that's very difficult to make
progress on but the the idea hasn't gone
away and in fact there was a report just
a couple of weeks ago from London the
insurance company who this is based on a
fairly large survey of people from three
different generations who are in the
sort of different stages of expecting to
pass on inheritance or receive an
inheritance or maybe get to give town
from inheritance and see it go straight
down through children what they found in
this survey is that actually even if you
say in your will that no or my wealth
will go to my children or if you don't
write a will and so that sort of happens
as the default option that doesn't
necessarily mean that that's what your
descendants are going to do and what
they found is that when looking at baby
boomers and this was specifically
essentially people who are expecting to
receive a housing based inheritance from
their parents in the not-too-distant
future the majority of these people said
that they expect to pass some or all of
this inheritance straight on to the next
generation but they did point out also
the sort of major flaw in this idea if
you want to talk
about in terms of social equality or the
numbers they gave they're only around
four million of the 17 million people in
the 25 to 44 age group they're in the
fortunate position of having
grandparents with housing wealth
now obviously housing wealth is not the
only sort of wealth even though this is
held the conversation is normally framed
but it does point out no the the very
significant point that whatever sort of
inheritance system you set up it's
clearly going to be most beneficial for
the descendants of rich people and so
you might throw up your hands and say
well you know there's no point in
exploiting this at all you know we're
clearly not going to solve all the
problems of society by doing this and
that's absolutely true
but I think it's still valid to ask the
question well if we tweaked inheritance
tax laws or if we made it a little bit
easier to set up the descendants trust
the David Halpern was arguing for what
will be the long-term effects on society
it's clearly not going to be a universal
solution for everything but will it make
things perhaps just a little bit better
in the long run okay so this is where
the agent-based models come in this is
where we can test it out now this video
is just sort of a conceptual picture of
what an agent-based model is the basic
idea is that it is a computer simulation
of some sort of complex system and the
the specific point of an agent-based
model as opposed to other sorts of
models that works from the micro level
behavior and from that works out what do
the macro level results will be so
instead of trying to go from the top
down of say predicting what the economy
is going to look like in ten years
straight from the top level figures you
would look at well how do people spend
money and earn money and know how does
finance move things around and just play
that out and then from that see okay
what are the top-line numbers that we're
most interested in so in this particular
example it's just different colored
circles and each of these circles is one
agent and they're each following a set
of rules that defines their
behavior now the agents in an
agent-based model can be anything really
in what I'll be talking about today
they're individuals but they could
equally in other circumstances be
households they could be entire
corporations or countries if you sort of
extend the definition of an agent-based
model a little bit then you could have
you could talk about individual agents
being galaxies or being molecules you
know anything where you can sort of
define the set of rules that govern
their behavior then you can essentially
make Canadian space model out of it
so as I've been saying you you need to
give your agents a set of behavioral
rules if you can't write down what those
rules are
you can't build a model and often
there's going to be some sort of set of
assumptions that go into that but no
that's that's how it goes
you also will typically give your agents
and environment interact with know which
could cover a sorts of different things
but will often include the other agents
themselves and that's how you can get
things like sort of flocking behavior or
something like that where the actions of
one agent depends very strongly on the
actions of the agents that are around it
now once you've set up your behavior
rules and the the environment and you've
sort of got your agents ready to go then
you pretty much just press play and see
what happens and measure whatever
results it is that you're interested in
okay so if you want to build out an
agent based model of the inheritance
system then we need to think first about
or what data do we need to gather in
order to make this feasible well there
are a couple of obvious ones to start
with we need to know what the birth rate
and the death rate ask that we get sort
of the right numbers of people going
through the population we need to know
what I've caught here the the coupling
rate now if this was a very sort of
traditional Victorian society then we
could just look up the marriage rate and
that would be okay in the 21st century
about 50% of children are born to
married parents and 50% unmarried
parents
and so we need to know for the mag
parents it's very easy to find out what
the rate of marriages every marriage in
this country is recorded and we can just
look that up for the unlined parents
obviously we know a lot less about how
often people form long-term
relationships but now we do know a lot
about the birth rate to both married and
unmarried mothers and so we can if we
put the purposes of this model just sort
of define coupling to be forming a
relationship that has the same 4:30 rate
as marriage on average then we can
simply sort of take the marriage rate
compare it to the birth rate and just
extrapolate out the marriage rate to get
the right number of couples being formed
in the model so as the model concern we
don't care if they're actually married
or not now as well as coupling we need
to know about uncoupling not all
relationships last forever and this
becomes important in the model because
if you have children with one partner
but then split up then you may go and
have more children with a second partner
and obviously that plays into how your
wealth gets spread around after you die
so that sort of defines the really raw
demographic data of just how many people
do you have and how they related to each
other we also need to know about the the
distribution of wealth very obviously
and also the distribution of incomes if
we are going to play the simulation out
of a long period of time then it's not
just your wealth now that it's important
it's how this plays out over decades or
a hundred years another useful piece of
information is the the connection
between income and education which
unsurprisingly is quite strong now there
are a lot of other things that income
depends on but education is a
particularly important one for this
model because there is a very strong
relationship between parents and
children's education if your parents
went to university you are much more
likely to go to the University than
someone whose parents didn't and so now
you can putting everything else aside
from these two points the media to be me
that you have quite a strong correlation
between your parents income and your own
income and just through having similar
levels of education now the great thing
about living in the UK is that as
mentioned particularly by the full fact
people earlier almost all of this
information is available from the Office
of National Statistics the ons they
really are a fantastic resource I cannot
recommend them highly enough if you're
building any sort of models of this sort
if you ever need to set up a
representative population of the UK then
you will almost certainly be able to
find what you need on their website and
it's just free to search and download ok
so that kind of defines yet bits of data
that will be going into the model we
also need to write down what our set of
behavioral rules will be now the way
ABMS typically work is we talk about a
tick loop this is just a for loop that's
going round and each cycle of the loop
is a fixed amount of time that we call a
tick no just the same as a clock ticking
onwards now you're your choice of tick
size depends entirely on what you're
trying to model but in this case a year
is a fairly suitable choice it's the
sort of timescales that you're
interested in in terms of families and
no birth and death and inheritance okay
so what happens within this tick loop
well each time you go around your agents
all go older all of the the adults in
this simulation money and they save or
invest 5% of that income now obviously
this is horribly simplistic you know
real people's finances are much more
complex than this it's also kind of very
optimistic in that everyone has an
income everyone is able to put away some
of it I said so just explain this 5%
saving investing this isn't just what
you can put into a bank account
now if you've got if you have a mortgage
and they're paying into that the NAT is
effectively an investment as well
because you're you're paying into the or
your housing wealth in that way see how
so saying this is a very simple model
and for so the future improvements of
the model there's probably the first
place that I'd go to to try and get a
bit more of a realistic look at how
people really earn money but this should
do for our purposes of just having a
sort of sort of simple idea of how
people might on average earn money in
order to test out the different types of
inheritance which is what we're really
interested in okay so another sort of
simple and optimistic bit is that all
adults in the model and 3% interest on
wealth and again this is not just your
actual interest on your savings account
this includes increases in property
value as well if you own property and
again this is simple this is averaging
over the fact that some people do have
property that's going up in value some
people do not and so their effective
interest rate who should be a lot lower
but we don't want to do a full housing
simulation for this particular purpose
so we'll just leave it at that average
for now okay so if your agent at this
particular tip is single than they have
a chance of forming a couple and I'll
come back later to some of the details
of that but essentially just look for
people who are kind of similar to you in
in age and wealth and then in every year
you have some chance of forming
relationship with them okay but then
also as I said if you're in a couple
there's a chance of splitting up and as
I was saying before these things vary
the the exact details of the
probabilities here a very strong
informed by the earnest data that we
have again also if you're in a couple
then you have a chance of having a baby
in any one year so
the sake of simplicity there are no
twins or triplets or anything and this
model you can only have one baby a year
as far as I'm concerned so then when you
get towards the later part of your life
when the agents at the age of 65 then
they retire and half of their wealth
just sort of disappears now what's
happening here is that that wealth is
going into an annuity well this is just
when you sort of pay out a lump sum and
then that is what guarantees your income
for the rest of your life and so you
know you know that you're not going to
run out of money that you've got some
yet you have guaranteed income
but as far as your inheritance is
concerned then that money is no longer
accessible to you now if you die at the
age of 66 then you kind of lost out
because now you've put all this money
away and then it just disappears but you
do it because if you instead happen to
live to the age of a hundred then you
still have that income throughout the
rest of your life okay but also in the
model we say that once you have retired
you're not earning anymore and you just
sort of gradually run down your savings
you know you're living a bit off that as
well as what's coming out of your
annuity and then of course the really
crucial thing for this model is that all
agents have a chance of dying in any
given year and again this is entirely
driven by the ONS data on on death rates
at different ages for men and women
okay so then comes the the bit that we
actually sort of interested in testing
out these different inheritance rules so
there are two based options essentially
we have kind of the default that is what
most people are doing now which is that
if you have a partner who's alive then
you give all of your money to them if
your partner has pre deceased you or if
you've split up then your wealth is
split
Queen your children the other option is
again if you have a sliding partner then
the money goes to them first but
otherwise instead of going to your
children the money gets put into a
descendent trust the things that David
Halpern was arguing for and this
descendants trust is for your
grandchildren and great-grandchildren in
indeed sort of default setup we put into
the model and the way it works is that
so that money is there it's accumulating
interest while it's in this trust and
when the the beneficiaries reach the age
of 18 then they get no their fair share
of the money that's in there if they're
already eighteen moreover when you die
then then they get that money
immediately and to compare these two
different options we just run the model
twice we run at once where everyone
takes option one and run at once where
everyone takes option two and we compare
the results of the two now obviously
this is kind of unrealistic and that
we're saying that either you know sixty
million people waiting for one decision
or sixty million people make the other
decision but we do this just to give us
the largest possible baseline to compare
the results and yeah produce the largest
effect possible to see really what
revisions that what we're interested in
here is just as the effect positive or
negative okay so in terms of actually
building this in Python I'm not going to
show you any code or anything and if
you're interested in having a look then
there's a github repository that has the
the model code and the raw data in it as
well but just as a brief description and
this kind of describes most of the
models we build at sound table we use
the just the the familiar open source
packages that most of you will know from
your day-to-day work as well we pandas a
lot particular for the initial data
ingestion and processing the the
simulation itself is mostly
built-in numpy we can represent a BMS
very simply using numpy by just
assigning each variable of interest to
an array so for example the age of all
of our agents is an integer array of
length the number of agents the wealth
of our agents is a floating point array
of length the number of agents and
because we're able to write down what
the paper balls are was raised to turn
that then into a few lines of numpy code
that manipulate those are raised within
each tick side by comes in normally just
when we need sparse matrices which if
for this particular model was useful for
keeping track of who is related to who
but then one of the things about a BMS
and one of the reasons they've not been
used too much until quite recently is
that they're very noisy there's a lot of
random choices that are being made at
every step along the way and yeah what
this means is that to get any useful
results out of it you really have to run
the thing hundreds or maybe thousands of
times and aggregate results up take some
sort of average and so you know to do
that suddenly it doesn't really become
feasible to run on my laptop and so we
turn to AWS for that and I've really got
to give a massive amount of credit to
the dev team at stand table we've put
together some wonderful services so that
I the data scientists don't really have
to worry about what's happening there I
can just say give me a cluster with 200
cores and fund my model a thousand times
and it happens and the results come back
and I'm a happy take a scientist okay so
let's look at some actual results then
and the nice thing about a BMS is that
you don't just have to look at the the
top level picture which is what's of
most models will tell you you can drill
right down and look at what is an
individual in my model doing this is
really interesting from a curiosity
point of view and it's also a matter
use force of sanity check on everything
you're doing you need to if yeah if you
look at the individual level results and
people are doing weird stupid things
that make no sense
did you know there's a problem that you
need to can't fix okay but let's look at
the life history of one of the agents
from the model I've caught a Mary and
this is the version of the model where
you have direct inheritance that people
pass their wealth down to their children
now so this is it was starting in 2016
running outwards Mary was born in was
about twenty thirty and a yeah we look
at the the sort of vertical lines first
what we're seeing is that at the age of
about twenty two she formed a couple
with someone they had three children
over the next few years
unfortunately they separated when she
was aged forty she didn't form any
further relationships after that you see
there until she was in her late 70s this
is now into the 22nd century now this
blue lying is tracking her wealth over
this period and what we find is that see
sort of starts off with nothing
she's working she earns throughout her
lifetime this is where she retires and
puts half of that into an annuity and
then when she's aged about 70 she
inherits quite a large amount from from
her parents who the second foot pounds
has just passed away but she only
actually lives a few years longer than
that so it doesn't actually make a
massive amount of difference to in that
sense if instead we switch over to the
version of the model with these
descendants trusts his agent that I've
called Paul he was born a few years
before Mary and he formed a relationship
to similar aged her in his early 20s
actually has five children and and he
stays with that same partner for the
rest of his life until he dies in
his 80s but what we can see here is that
we in food look at as wealth we have we
have three separate distinguishable
jumps where he has inherited some wealth
from his grandparents or
great-grandparents and obviously this is
happening too much earlier time of his
life than it did for Mary so although
they each actually inherit a similar
amount in their lives and actually earn
reasonably similar numbers as well I
think it's perhaps slightly high for
Paul but if I flip between the two you
can see that really at all times in his
eyes Paul is the wealthier of the two
because he's had this injection of
wealth as an earlier time in his life
okay but that's just sort of two
individuals we really care about the
population of results so to look at this
and we use a measure called the Gini
coefficient some of you may have worked
with this value before but essentially
what you do is you line up your entire
population ordered by how much wealth
they have and then you take the
cumulative sum along that's ordering now
if if everyone in your population has
exactly the same amount of wealth the
new would plot this straight line curve
that's the amount the cumulative
fraction of wealth is directly equal to
the cumulative population fraction and
that corresponds to a Gini coefficient
of zero that is the least unequal
Society you can have if there is some
distribution of wealth than the first
people will contribute a small amount to
the cumulative fraction and so you get a
curve that drops below this equality
lying and the Gini coefficient is
actually mathematically equal to twice
this shaded area so this is for a
fraction of nor point four or eight if
we had a more unequal Society than that
goes up to 0.75 in this example if you
had the extreme case where one person
has all of the wealth and everybody else
is nothing then you get a line that just
comes straight up on the bottom and then
goes up to the top
and that's the Gini coefficient of one
okay so what does this actually look
like well we've got 150 year simulation
run two times and this is plotting the
the projected Gini coefficient for the
entire adult population and what we see
is that these intergenerational trust or
descendents trust they do really make a
significant difference that at a
population level you have a less unequal
Society as measured by the Gini
coefficient if you bring these things
into play but that was kind of obvious
because as governor Gavin Powell pointed
out you're giving money to people who
are at an early stage of their life who
typically have less wealth than older
people so the the next question is then
what within that population are you just
entrenching the inequality that's
already there or are you helping out so
if we look down just at the people sort
of aged twenty to thirty nine then
although these lines have narrowed a bit
there is the significant difference that
the people yet in the simulation with
the intergenerational trusts even if
you're just looking at one generation
because we have this effect of spreading
your wealth amongst more people then you
do get a less unequal Society the one
with alergy Gini coefficient okay so
there is some bad news it doesn't all
work out well one thing that kind of
confused me when I first saw this is
that descendants does actually increase
the correlation between your and your
parents wealth even though they've
reduced inequality they've increased
this correlation it took me a while to
work out why this is happening
but essentially it's because you're
often drawing from the same Trust's if
your great-grandparents make a
descendents trust then your parents
their grandchildren will inherit from it
and you'll inherit from it so you
actually are getting to the same pot of
cash to the two dwarf of so
once you notice that then it's not
surprising that we get this increased
correlation and indeed you can make the
effect go away if your trusts pay out
earning to one generation so if you make
it only for your grandchildren there's
also an issue around what's called a
sort of mating so there's the effect
that people tend to form relationships
with people who are similar to
themselves now similar can mean a lot of
different things obviously in this case
we're thinking about wealth and income
and so there is a parameter in the model
that defines sort of how important is
that to people how likely are they to
match up with someone who has very
similar wealth to them or how likely are
they to just pick someone essentially at
random and so we continue this parameter
and see what the different outcomes are
the the dashed line is what I was
showing before and I should say this is
just among the young people in this
particular plot so the - lying is what
we believe to be roughly the the
strength of sort of mating in the real
world if you take it away then the
sender trusts have a stronger effect if
you increase their source of mating they
have a weaker effect so there is this
relationship here but even in this
strong case where the strength of sorts
of mating is twice what we believe it be
in the real world then there is still a
difference that lasts for at least 100
years in that the descendants trust have
improved the situation as far as in
quality is concerned okay so just to
wrap up and give you the takeaway
messages the sort of social takeaway
here is that descendants trusts words
overall decrease in equality and they do
this in two ways firstly by transferring
wealth to younger people who on average
have less at the moment and also by
spreading wealth around even within a
generation there is a site caveat and
that they may increase the correlation
between you and your parents wealth and
that sort of unfairness No maybe an
important factor in deciding what to do
about these
and and also the strength of a sort of
mating and I have no idea what the
predictions are for how was automating
will be in the future
but it is an important effect on on how
well the the trusts work with nd the
sort of technical take home from this is
that all these sorts of things and many
born the sides can be explored using
agent-based models their really great
tool set for this sort of exploratory
work particularly for complex
interacting systems okay so I'll just
put up my contact details and there was
the github repository where you can take
a look at the model you can play around
the parameters play around the rules and
I'd love to see if anyone comes up with
some new conclusions from the model
thank you big thanks James a question
how long did you run it for and what the
parameters were yes so and this was done
using an initial population of 10,000
agents now obviously that changes over
time as people are born and died
the and so on a single core then to get
the 150 years that takes I think about a
minute or something like that
so the the limiting factor in the
current implementation is in the
coupling system what it does at the
moment because in terms of fertility
it's the woman who's more important in
defining whether there will be a child
in the relationship then we sort of
choose the fraction of women who will
form couples in any one year and then
compare them to all of the eligible men
and that comparison is quite so and
particularly as your population grows
then obviously it kind of blows up a bit
with a better implementation of that
sort of system where you're a bit
smarter about which men you're comparing
to the women then I think you could
improve the performance quite a lot
how do you deal with volatility of
people's earnings I mean if you're
looking at their own aesthetic it would
be easy to assume that the top 1% was
the same set of people year after year
but maybe it's people who are selling
businesses of massive temporary
increases in their income yeah and
that's a very good point this one that's
not really dealt with in the model as it
stands the only change that we have in
there is that as you as you grow older
your earning potential increases and
that's pretty easy to pull out from DNS
data it would be very interesting to
look into that the sort of issues of
volatility both in terms of income and
in terms of wealth as well birds yeah
that's not something we've had time to
do yet yeah it is and this model it was
actually relatively easy to do that
because it's really the more data well
the more useful data you have the easier
it is to do this and that we can simply
look at the earnest data for debts for
example and say ok if you are a male age
63 you have an X percent chance of dying
each year and so that just goes straight
in no reason don't have to worry about
it really it's a well-defined rule the
difficulties come with a BMS where you
don't know your information so well I
work a lot in commercial applications
where you want to know what the
probability is someone choosing
particular product is for example and
that's much less constrained so in those
sorts of situations you have to look at
what data you do have you look at a lot
of survey data and other sort of
monitoring data and find different ways
to match the model up against the
reality because in this model we only
had actually one tunable counter which
the assorted mating in a commercial
model that might be very many parameters
and we've got to find some different
pieces of information to calculate each
of those against yeah so in this case it
it really was the sort of fairly
simplistic income yes what income and
education are the main things there in
terms of interaction with an environment
and yeah this model has a very simple
implementation of those it is no
literally just the rules that I put up
there translated into numpy code so you
know as pointed out there's a lot more
that could be done there but yeah it's
just a matter of how much we have time
to investigate and really trying to
focus on the things that are important
to the inheritance myths
[Music]